Why her?
Why Miki?
Why did you choose her?
Well Miki; because first of all I've worked once with Miki.
In "Silk", right?
"Silk" and then immediately...
You fell in love?
...fell in love; I found the charm of Miki as a fabulous actress.
And she, Miki, brings way more than her beauty to the part...
...like she has, I feel, an aura when she walks in the room.
She has soul, a deep soul...
Right.
...and I was looking for another opportunity to work with her.
And so I'm writing a script now where she has a part in that.
So, I mean it's circumstantial.
But also, if we take the idea that one actress would play these three women,...
...it's hard to think of or find a better choice than Miki.
She has the youth, beautiful youth...
...and maturity; you can see her going a Western style, her eyes meet the lead.
But also, she's a well - educated in traditional kimono dance and tea ceremonies...
...so she also carries a very traditional Japanese culture.
So in my mind, I think she's just perfect.